when a cowpoke finds a love crafty and
whole in the earth what's he going to do
my guesses he'll probably say who Nelly
or something the opening scene begins on
a haunting Dark Night where a guy named
Royal Abbott carries a dead body on his
shoulder with his voiceover overlapping
the visuals he narrates about the Greek
god of time Kronos who used to carry a
sickle to separate the two worlds the
known and the unknown Royal throws the
body into a void and right then someone
shines a flashlight on him 3 days
earlier Royal wakes up beside his wife
Cecilia who recounts her recurring dream
turns out she frequently dreams about
their missing daughter-in-law Rebecca
reuniting with her granddaughter Cecilia
asks him not to share her dream with
anyone which he never does the couple
lives with their two sons Perry and
Rhett and Perry's daughter Amy it
appears that Rhett is aiming to be a
professional bull rider just like his
father but he still has to practice a
lot more for that as of right now all he
is is professional one night
before going to sleep Amy asks Cecilia
about how she and Royal met in response
Cecilia tells her that Royal had a very
rough childhood and that he never knew
his real parents however he doesn't
remember the trauma one day something
happened that made him run away from his
home and show up at Cecilia's family
ranch the place where they're currently
living meanwhile Royal feels an eerie
presence and hears some strange sounds
around him but fails to figure out what
it is at the same time their neighbor
Wayne Tillerson also hears the droning
sound and senses something aess he then
makes a call to Cecilia to warn her that
something is coming but the ladder hangs
up the phone believing he's drunk the
following morning Royal finds out that
their two cows have gone missing
panicked he alerts his sons and the
three prepare to go looking for their
missing cattle just before they leave
they're stopped by a hitchhiker named
Autumn she introduces herself as a poet
and requests that they allow her to camp
at their Ranch for a few days despite
hesitating at first Royal eventually
agrees when she pays him some bucks I
like bucks says the bull rider following
this he and his sons head towards the
fence which is dividing the Abbott and
tellers ranches there they are
approached by Wayne's Three Sons Luke
Billy and Trevor the eldest son Luke
informs Royal that as per the County
assessment his fences are nearly half a
mile over the Tillerson property thus he
gives him 30 days to move them after
their brief discussion Royal and his
sons split up to continue their search
Royal reaches the western part of his
Ranch where he discovers a humongous
hole with seemingly no bottom and some
kind of cosmic dust floating over it o
Nelly says Royal puzzled he throws a
rock into the vastness but it doesn't
hit the bottom he then proceeds to stick
his hand into the abyss a stupid stupid
idea which causes him to experience a
vision of himself walking back home and
greeting deputy sheriff Joy this freaks
him out so he hastily removes his hand
and returns upon arriving home the exact
moment that he saw earlier plays out in
real time thereby hinting at the fact
that the cosmic hole allows the person
to look into the future deputy sheriff
Joy is there to inform Royal and his
family that the FBI is going to stop
looking for Rebecca due to a lack of New
Leads Royal is worried about Rebecca and
tillerson's legal notice but his mind is
mostly occupied by the mythical pit the
next day he visits the hole again he
tries to fill it with soil and cover it
up with a tarp but his efforts prove
futile frustrated he screams into the
void which is hilarious just shrieking
because his Cowboy brain can't handle
this until he spots a bison with
two arrows piercing its body as the
Bison moves away Royal regains composure
and seeks out Autumn he strikes up a
conversation with her trying to
understand her motives for living all
alone in the wilderness however she
changes the topic and inquires if he is
willing to sell the ranch she even
starts naming prices causing him to
become skeptical he then challenges her
to prove that she has money but she says
that she'll do it on a condition he
spills one of his Secrets puzzled by the
request Royal walks away from the
conversation later that night Perry and
Rett go to the bar to drown their
sorrows they are still Shattered by the
fact that the FBI is backing away from
the investigation around Rebecca
Unfortunately they get into a scuffle
with Trevor and Rhett ends up knocking
him down he then asks his brother to
wait there while he brings the truck and
Rhett's absence Trevor makes an
off-handed remark about Rebecca this
enrages Perry so much that he punches
the guy to death he soon regrets his
actions but it's too late shocked and
scared the two brothers load the dead
body into the truck and drive back home
upon arrival they hide their truck in
the barn however they're caught by their
father who is understandably angry about
it but vows to protect his sons he
orders Rhett to clean the truck while
deciding to handle the body disposal
himself don't worry bud just going to
throw it in that God dang hole not long
after Luke and Billy knock on the door
to inquire about Trevor Perry answers
the door acting as if he knows nothing
while they talk he toggles the barn
light to discreetly signal Rhett and
Royal about the impending threat shortly
after the tillerson's Discover tire
tracks in the dirt which leads them
directly to the barn as if there aren't
tire tracks all over this place they
bust their way in and find the truck
only it's filled with hay bales turns
out Royal is already Galloping away on
his horse towards the Mystic hole
intending to dispose of the body but
along the way a burst of lightning
startles the horse causing Trevor to
fall down he then quickly carries the
body on his shoulders reaches the hole
and hurls it in this is the same scene
from the start of the show the one who
shines the flashlight on him is none
other than Autumn she begins reciting
the story of Kronos while slowly walking
towards him in an unexpected turn of
events she holds him with tenderness and
then suddenly pushes him into the abyss
in the next scene we see royal
inexplicably waking up in the middle of
a field amid a downpour as he rises to
his feet perplexed about the events his
horse appears he then returns home with
a wound in his leg probably due to the
fall upon arrival he sees his sons and
wife waiting for him in the kitchen with
Cecilia now aware of the secret
following this the family discusses
their next move but Royal claims that
there's nothing to talk about because
Trevor's body is already gone when
Cecilia asks about Autumn Royal assures
that he'll track her down soon on the
other hand the Tillerson enlist Sheriff
joy to investigate Trevor's
disappearance Luke H are a bloodstained
belt buckle from Trevor which he
retrieved from outside the bar earlier
despite her initial lack of Interest Joy
is compelled to look into the case
because the election for the new sheriff
is in 28 days and the Tillerson boys can
help swing the upcoming vote in her
favor elsewhere Rhett goes to meet her
childhood Crush Maria who is one of the
few people who witnessed the tussle
between him and forever he asks her out
on a date with the agenda to keep things
quiet if the teller inquire about what
happened on that fateful night later
that day Royal and Perry visit their
lawyer to talk about reversing the legal
order of shifting their fence however
the lawyer suggests they hand over the
piece of land to Tillerson without any
fuss as they never lose a legal battle
hearing this Royal decides to talk to
Wayne in person upon reaching their
residence he offers 200 acres of land
from his South pasture to sort out the
matter but Wayne is obs obsessed with
the West portion this indicates that he
also knows about the mysterious hole
frustrated Royal decides to take the
matter to court in the meantime Amy
spots autumn in the hill looking at some
occult symbols resembling the Abbott
family brand when the little girl asks
what she's doing Autumn says that she's
been drawing the design of the brand her
whole life and now she's here at the
Abbott Ranch upon learning that Amy is
an Abbott she indirectly inquires about
Royal and gets surprised to learn that
he is still alive at night Royal conveys
to his family that he wants to move the
cattle from the West pasture to the east
his family doesn't understand his
motives and thinks he is losing his mind
but only Royal knows what horror lies in
the west pasture it's that freaking hole
man it's freaking me out after dinner
everyone goes to their beds while he
sneaks out into the barn and pulls out
an old picture of his parents just then
Autumn arrives there and asks what he's
looking for Royal evades her question
and demands that she leave the barn
however she refuses as she knows about
his secret which she uses as leverage
against him through their conversation
we learn that Autumn like Royal lacks
memories of her life before the age of
nine she then asks what he saw in that
pit and how he survived it the scene
flashes back to Royal falling through
the hole and landing on a field beside
the same Mystic hole he found himself
surrounded by big bright lights and the
Army pointing guns at him as he shifted
his attention he saw Autumn dressed in a
uniform that made him believe that she
she was either working for the
governments or the drilling company
shortly after Cecilia walked towards him
and informed him that she had already
died 2 years ago in that timeline she
also revealed that the ranch doesn't
belong to them anymore as Royal tried to
decipher this information his wife
discreetly whispered in his ear and
asked him to run moments later Luke came
out of the crowd and shot him in the leg
which explains how he got the wound
earlier in a desperate attempt to save
himself Royal jumped back into the hole
returning back to his original timeline
forget the Bulls Royal is now a
professional whole rider in the next
scene Sheriff Joy heads to a store to
put up a poster for her election but she
inadvertently walks into a robbery she
bravely subdues the robber and hauls him
into the back of her car while driving
him to the station the robber begins
ranting about the real problems in town
particularly the mysterious
disappearances of people meanwhile at
the tillerson's residence Wayne
instructs his sons to offer Royal a
million do for his West pasture Luke
reminds him that their court hearing is
next month and they're going to get that
land anyway however Wayne sticks to his
decision to make an offer which upsets
Luke as he thinks his father is
prioritizing land acquisition over
finding Trevor during one of her walks
Autumn comes across the same bison with
two arrows in it she casually takes one
out but the creature leaves before she
can pull out the next one following this
she walks around the streets where she
discovers Royal's vehicle outside a bar
she enters the bar and com com across
Perry the two then have a brief chitchat
regarding Rebecca's disappearance the
same evening Rhett is preparing for his
bull riding competition when Joy pays
him a visit as they Converse she
discloses that according to the forensic
report the blood on the Buckle matches
his DNA in response red admits that he
was at the scene that night but he
doesn't know anything about the blood
Joy knows that he's hiding something but
she doesn't ask any further questions
and departs later we see Rhett under a
lot of stress as he fears that he will
be apprehended soon but despite this he
manages to score high points finally
securing a victory in the competition
later he goes on a date with Maria and
gets drunk after a lovely dinner the two
share a romantic kiss outside the
restaurant before departing in an
inebriated State RH then goes behind a
cop's car and urinates which results in
him being arrested later at the police
station Joy approaches him and convinces
him to reveal whatever he knows about
Trevor this time he finally admits that
he got into a scuffle with him however
he doesn't reveal the entire truth
hiding the fact that Perry was the one
to beat him to death shortly after Royal
arrives at the station to bail out his
son while waiting he discreetly steals
Trevor's Buckle so that he can dispose
of it in the mysterious hole on their
way back home Royal confides in Rhett
revealing a long held secret about his
family he discloses that his mother
didn't pass away during his childhood
after his father's death Royal was so
depressed that he abandoned his mother
and youngest sister and came to Abbott
Ranch the following day Royal visits
Autumn who is still camping on his Ranch
he inquires the reason as to why she
pushed him earlier to which she vaguely
replies that she wanted to know what
would happen he then proposes a deal she
can remain on the ranch if she keeps all
of these secrets to herself which she
agrees to as he shakes hands with Autumn
the mountain behind him inexplicably
vanishes the strange sight is witnessed
by joy as well but before she can
comprehend the situation it reappears
later on Amy goes for a little hike in
the nearby Forest where she discovers
Trevor's lifeless body alarmed the
little girl hurries back home and shares
the discovery with her family in order
to divert suspicion Royal makes a clever
move he calls the deputy sheriff and
notifies her about the dead body
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching